hey you guys flickers of fear time
and we're doing another giallo movie on
this installment which i'm always very
excited about
as most people that follow the channel
no i'm a big fan of jello movies
and one of the reasons that i started
this series was to review more glo
movies
as well as other ones too but i'm really
glad to be getting to this one because
this one that is one that
i saw many many years ago which i'll get
into in a minute and then
shutter just added it not too long ago
as of this recording so i was
excited to get to see it a second time
and sort of analyze it for the show
this is the 1972 film what have you done
to solange now the reason that i i guess
the reason that i ended up watching this
and the reason that i'd even heard of it
was that this was interestingly the film
debut of the american actress camille
keaton
who i knew from the infamous rape
revenge classic
i spit on your grave so i was very
interested to see this italian movie
it's actually an italian
west german co-production um but i was
interested to see what her first role
was now she's not not in it a great
deal i don't even think she actually
talks in it she probably doesn't show up
until about two-thirds of the way
through
but she does play the titular solange so
we'll get into that in
a little bit now this was directed by
massimo delemano he's directed a bunch
of italian movies although none
other ones that i've seen uh however i
will note that he was the
cinematographer
on fistful of dollars and for a few
dollars more so you know there's that
um and this basically it's it's a very
i don't want to say it's a very standard
giallo but it is kind of like
your story where all of these sort of
women
are being picked off in a particularly
in this case in a very particularly
sexual
way by a black gloved killer and
somebody who's not a cop has to figure
out
what exactly is going on and that's
pretty much what happens in this one
i will say there's something really
interesting tonally about
this one and maybe like i don't know
like i guess a lot of jlo movies sort of
have this
but it was something that really stood
out to me a lot while i was watching
this particular one
is that this one has a really
interesting
balance between being really really
sleazy and exploitative in the sense
that there's
just so much gratuitous nudity and it's
like and it's set at a catholic girls
school so it's like i mean obviously
these are not
underage girls i think they're supposed
to be um because they're supposed to be
like not
college students but i mean they're
clearly much older so it's okay but
i mean there's so many scenes of just
kind of like hey here's all these girls
in the shower and here's all this
and but it does kind of make sense you
know with the plot of the movie because
it is sort of a sexual
uh story like the thematically it's a
you know
it does have something to do with that
so you know now as i said this movie
was supposedly and i don't know how
close this is because i've never read
the book
but you know there were a lot of giallo
movies not so much jello movies but i
guess kind of more the crime
movies that were based on uh edgar
wallace's
stories uh novels he's a british author
and he wrote a lot of kind of noir
you know crime fiction and so a lot of
giallo
uh movies and uh the later
or the the german crimi movies which are
kind of the same or like you know police
procedural type stuff
were sort of based on his stuff so they
kind of marketed
what have you done to solange as being
based on
one of edgar wallace's books which i
think is called the clue of the new pin
because there is kind of like a little
green pin that you know is sort of a
plot point in this
and as i said i haven't read the book
i've read some of edgar wallace's other
stuff but not that one in particular
so i don't know how close it is but from
what i could determine it's
it's pretty uh not all that close so i
guess they were just trying to
appeal to that market you know what i
mean because as i said so many of these
crime films in germany particularly
where they were kind of popular
uh were based on edgar wallace's stuff
so they wanted to kind of play up
that adaptation angle even if it wasn't
exactly what was
going on so what you have in this one is
your main character
is this dude named enrico uh rossetti i
think is his last name rossetti or
merceti yeah something like that uh he's
played by
fabio teste who the whole time i was
watching this movie i was kind of like
man that dude is so familiar he looks a
lot like a young sean connery actually
maybe that's why
um or he actually looks like sean
connery's brother that was in operation
double double 007 if you guys have seen
that one that was on mystery science
theater
so maybe that's why maybe i was
confusing him with that guy because i
looked at his wikipedia page
and he's been in a [ __ ] ton of italian
movies but i hadn't but none that i had
seen
except for the luchio folchi movie
contraband which i did see but it was so
long ago that i don't think i would have
remembered him from that
but i don't know he was just like super
familiar and i couldn't figure out where
i'd seen him but yeah so he's kind of
the main character
he plays a professor at this catholic
girls school which is in england so this
is actually it's dubbed like most of
these jlo movies are but you have
american actors you have italian actors
you have german actors you have
everybody and everybody just kind of
it looked like everybody was speaking
english but it seemed like everything
was dubbed over
uh you know so you didn't get as many
accents you know what i mean
or the accents weren't as thick perhaps
i'm not really sure but this is actually
set in uh
london so there's a catholic girls
school he's a professor there i guess
i don't i didn't know if he was just
like an italian guy or if he also taught
italian but he also taught jim i think
because one of the classes he went into
was like a gym class clearly
so he is he's married to one of the
other professors whose name is herta
who's a german woman i kind of want to
get into this a little later on because
it's just i don't know this was just
kind of like funny to me
but uh she's kind of like a cold you
know
uptight kind of [ __ ] or whatever so uh
so enrico has been kind of you know
getting the little trim
on the side uh in the form of a student
named elizabeth now at the very
beginning of this movie
elizabeth and enrico are in this rowboat
out on the thames
and they're making out and elizabeth
she seems uh she's kind of like a good
girl you know so i think she's kind of
like reluctant she like she's into him
but she's reluctant to
let him go all the way i guess you know
what i mean like the parlance of the day
back then but so so while they're kind
of making out in the rowboat
like she glances over and she sees what
appears to be
a girl like with her shirt kind of open
like running through the woods as though
she's running away from somebody
she sees what she thinks is somebody
chasing her like a shadowed figure
and then she kind of sits up and she's
like what the hell is that and he's just
like man stop it up
you know you're you're just like trying
to make excuses for like not having sex
with me or whatever and she's like yeah
that's totally what it is
um but she's like yeah maybe i didn't
see anything blah blah so then they
start making out again
and then she sees something else she
sees like the flash of a knife and she's
absolutely sure it's a knife so at this
point he's getting blue balls and he's
really pissed off and he's like look if
you
you know i can't be that i think he has
this great lie like i can't be that good
a lover if you if you just keep getting
distracted by
like random [ __ ] you see in the woods
that you're probably not even seeing
because you're a girl and blah blah
your imagination and whatnot so he gets
pissed off and rosie back to the thing
now as he uh later on when he's
at home he's his wife is listening to
the radio and he hears that indeed
they did find a girl murdered on the
banks of the thames exactly where that
rowboat was
uh and she was stabbed with a knife so
he decides that he's going to go down to
the crime scene and see what's what he's
like oh my girlfriend's not crazy after
all maybe she did actually see something
so he goes down there
i will say that the particularly sexual
violence
in this movie it's really i don't even
know what the word for it is but
basically this killer kills women by
stabbing them in their vaginas and just
leaving the knife sticking out of it and
um you know so there you go
like i said just know what you're
getting into it's not super super gory
but i
but i am just going to say that that
they do kind of you know you know
there's a vagina and there's a big knife
sticking out of it so
you know just like i said know what
you're getting into so at this point
he's kind of like well [ __ ] and so he
talks to his girlfriend and
the girlfriend's like well i should go
to the cops then because you know
obviously i
saw something and it's even though it
wasn't much of anything and i can't
remember it all she can remember like i
said is seeing the figure
she said it looked like a man but she
said quote unquote something funny there
was something funny about him
which as i said that's another very
standard uh you know thing of giallo
movies
you have a thing where there's a witness
who saw a crime
you know or they didn't even realize it
was a crime at the time but then they
saw like an unusual detail
that keeps bugging them because they
can't remember exactly what it was so
essentially that's what you have going
on
in this she's like i just you know i
know there was something funny about him
but i couldn't
like i can't place it like i can't
remember exactly what so
he's basically like well you can't go to
the police because they're gonna ask you
who you're with i'm gonna get in trouble
i'm gonna get fired
uh you know my wife will leave me blah
blah so they kind of
keep uh mum for the moment sadly the
fact that they keep mom well you know
ends up with uh yet another catholic
school girl the same
the same school getting murdered in
exactly the same exact
way and as it goes on
all of these particular girls are
getting picked off
and at this stage it almost seems like
well
enrico is the main suspect because
not only because all of these girls are
his students
uh and that he has a reputation not a
being like a poonhound or anything but
of being
sort of like you know kind of a casual
like friend to a lot of these young
girls and he's sort of you know he's
he's a young good-looking dude so uh he
sort of
has a reputation for hanging out with
them so he's seen as a as
a suspect and also he's being real cagey
because when um they took a picture of
the first
crime scene uh he was in the background
and also they found
a pen that he had dropped at the crime
scene so
they're thinking that maybe he had some
[ __ ] going on uh so two girls get killed
in the same exact way like i said
they're stabbed in their vaginas
and then very interestingly and i had
forgotten that this happened and i did
not even expect this at all and
like i said spoiler alert for a 1972
movie uh if you haven't seen it
i'm just gonna spoil it and spoil the
whole resolution because as i said it's
an old movie
and uh you know and it's hard to talk
about particularly a jello movie without
talking about kind of all the red
herrings and twists and turns and
whatnot
now right in like about the halfway part
of this movie elizabeth who
up to this point other than enrico is
probably like the main character because
she's
the original witness she's the one that
saw you know the [ __ ] like the girl
running through the woods and the knife
and everything
she ends up getting murdered as well now
she doesn't get murdered the same way
she's like drowned in
enrico's kind of uh love nest apartment
sort of thing
she's drown in the bathtub and she
doesn't get stabbed in the vagina
up to this point enrico's wife herta
who like i said in the first half of the
movie i don't know
i will say that they portray her a
little bit unsympathetically i guess
she's supposed to be
like frigid and so it's almost kind of
like
oh well what do you expect like he's
gonna go and
find some love elsewhere like with
students
which you know a little weird but
whatever was the 70s but the weird thing
about it is that
after elizabeth gets killed
and after they determine that not only
was elizabeth not sexually assaulted she
wasn't stabbed in the vagina or anything
like that
but they also determined that she was
still a virgin meaning that her and
enrico never did it
then some like herta is kind of like oh
okay well it's okay and then i guess she
wants to like come to his defense
because she knows
as much as she's pissed off about him
sniffing around all these
possibly underage girls you know she
doesn't want him she knows he's not a
murderer and she doesn't want him to get
convicted
so at that point they sort of rekindle
their romance or whatever
and she decides i'm going to help you
solve this crime because he's like man i
got to figure out like who
killed elizabeth who killed these other
two girls i got to figure out what's
going on
and um she's just kind of like well i'm
right there with you honey and we're
going to solve the mystery and indeed
they they do
so as i said a couple of other girls get
killed an older woman gets killed like a
middle-aged woman
it's interesting because she gets killed
after
one of the other girls who was a friend
of one of the victims
leaves a note in enrico's mailbox
that is like hey go see this woman whose
name is ruth holden she knows everything
but then he goes there and she's already
been dead and whoever did it killed her
dog as well so you know but yeah so
so this middle-aged woman also gets
stabbed in the vagina not with a knife
this time it looked like a [ __ ] like
a
scythe type of thing like one of those
you know a curvy
whatever those are so the only clues
that they have at this point
they find some hairs under elizabeth's
fingernails
and they determined that this hair is
dead hair
so they think that maybe this is from a
false beard
so they're looking for somebody that's
wearing that had been wearing a false
beard so
another thing that comes up is that all
of the girls that were killed
that they could determine had gone to
confession with this one particular
priest who wasn't the original
confessor and this dude indeed had a
beard they also enrico and his wife
also uncover that there was something to
do
with another girl named solange who had
been
friends with all of the girls that were
murdered they were kind of in this
little clique or whatever
but then she never came back and nobody
really knows what happened to her
so through some sleuthing and detective
work they actually
find this girl who is played by camille
keaton
and she seems to have some sort of
mental disability as in she can't really
speak she they call it i think infantile
regression
and you find out why she went like that
later because she was actually quote
normal
uh before but you know she had a
horrible traumatic thing and it made her
regress into an infantile state or
whatever so
as the as it goes on you discover that
all of the girls that were murdered
were part of this essentially sex club
so you know what i mean so it's all
these like catholic school girls and
their big thing was let's have this
little club which was signified by these
little pins that had like green
heads on them and they would like wear
them on their jackets to say hey i'm in
the sex club too whatever
they would kind of have all these orgies
and whatnot now it turned out that i
believe the previous year
solange had who was also being initiated
into the sex party or whatever
i guess during one of the orgies uh she
ended up getting pregnant
and all of the girls and took her to
ruth the middle aged woman that was
killed who um
also aside from being one of the girl's
housekeepers also
dabbled in abortion uh so she gave
solange an abortion that
was apparently so painful and traumatic
that it made solange regress to
an infantile state she could no longer
speak she could no longer do anything
so her dad decided to
basically not let her go back to school
uh and
sort of hid her away her last name you
know changed her last name everything
like that so they're
so they wouldn't know the association so
the killer it turned out
was solange's dad who was also another
teacher at the school except you didn't
know that because like i said he was
wearing a false beard and he was
pretending to be a priest
and he pretended to be a priest so he
could go into the confessionals and find
out which of the girls were in the sex
club and were responsible for solange
getting the abortion
that had made her you know regress into
an infantile state and
you know she was like psychologically
messed up so
that's why he was stabbing all the girls
in their vaginas as sort of like revenge
or payback or whatever so as i said this
is
a very it's a standard jello
in the sense of uh you know you got your
red herrings because you have like all
these teachers at the school because
at some point before elizabeth um you
know enrico's sort of mistress
girlfriend
gets killed she remembers the detail
of the murder that she's that she sort
of saw in the woods she's like oh i
remember now like the guy
i didn't see his face but i saw that he
was wearing what looked like a priest's
habit
so they're talking about maybe the
killer is a priest now as i said a lot
of these suspects this is the catholic
school
so pretty much all the teachers a lot of
the teachers are priests
so a lot of them are suspects so you
kind of have this rogues gallery
of suspects they don't really go a lot
into
making you feel oh maybe this one's them
and so you know there's a couple there's
one that's like super creepy and i can't
remember the actor's name but i've seen
him in a bunch of other ones and it's
like
that dude i can't man i wish i could
remember that actor's name because i
know i've seen him in some other uh
italian films
but that dude just has like creepy
guy like just all over his face so it's
like every movie he was in he was
probably just like that creepy dude
you know what i mean so and it didn't
help like the hairstyle that he had it's
like you have to see it to
know what i'm talking about but you know
they'll have a scene where it's like
that guy is like
peeping into the girl's shower you know
so it's like oh maybe it's that guy
but they don't really go too much into
that it's basically like
well enrico is the main suspect
although pretty early in the movie you
know it couldn't have been him because
you know because of various phone calls
that happened or various things that
happened when he wasn't around and all
this other kind of [ __ ]
for a little for a little while i kind
of thought maybe it was enrico's wife
herta maybe for five minutes i kind of
thought that i don't know if they were
trying to get me to think that
but i don't know it occurred to me
because i did kind of feel like
you know when they always say because i
think i mentioned this on maybe a blade
in the dark
like one of the last yellow movies i
reviewed that whenever
the witness says something about the uh
the killer was like
oh it's like a man but something funny
so i was like oh maybe it was a woman
like in man's clothing
but in this case the something funny was
that he had a priest habit on so it
wasn't the same thing but i did kind of
that i did make that connection
and i was kind of thinking oh maybe it
was her time maybe she's pissed off at
enrico like going and chasing after all
these like catholic school girls and
she's like
i'm gonna take care of this [ __ ]
problem right now but you know yeah it
wasn't
it ended up being like the dad so so it
was like kind of i don't
it's not a convoluted mystery it's
actually pretty straightforward
um but it is one that you kind of have
to pay attention all the details and
everything like that because a couple
details particularly toward the end like
about this one italian book and
everything i'm like wait what
but you know i kind of figured it out
like as it went on but yeah it's a very
it's a standard story but i really did
like
as i said i really liked the balance
between how
sleazy this was i don't want to give the
impression that it's
because i feel like a blade in the dark
was sleazier like had a sleazier vibe to
it
this has a little bit of a sleazy vibe
to it but it's also kind of classy at
the same time i'm not really sure if
that makes any sense
but if you've seen it you maybe will
know what i'm talking about
because like i said there's just so so
much gratuitous
nudity in this it's just kind of like
they have shower scenes for no reason
they have just
everybody's naked for no reason um well
i mean there is a reason
because you know they want people to
watch the movie but i'm just saying like
it you know in the universe of the movie
there's not really any reason to show
that
but so so it is kind of sleazy in that
aspect and like i said
any movie where women are getting
stabbed in the vagina
and they don't actually sugarcoat that
in any way and like they just pretty
much show it you know that's gonna have
a sleazy aspect but it
i don't know it's really hard to explain
because it really doesn't come across
as an exploitation film it's still a
very serious
mystery thriller type movie even with
these sort of
salacious aspects to it which i think is
like a really hard thing to pull off
i think this is why i think this might
be
this is easily in my top 10 jello movies
i mean there's just something that i
really really like about this one
i just really like i mean there's not a
lot of i'm
i don't know it's just kind of like i
like the whole setting of it i like the
way it's shot like the cinematography is
really nice
i just really like i don't know i really
like the mystery behind it i like that
it takes a while to figure it out i like
that they didn't
too obviously set up any red herrings
but there was a lot of possibilities
of who the killer could be but i don't
know there was just something about that
that really
appealed to me and i'm glad that i
finally got around to watching it again
because like i said i saw it probably
gosh 15 20 years ago just because i had
heard about it because camille keaton
was in it and this was her first movie
this was before she did i spit on your
grave actually so i was interested to
see it and also i was just kind of
getting started into being interested in
giallo movies back then
so you know i i didn't remember a lot
about it
uh from back then because i guess back
then it didn't make a huge impression
but watching it again now
now that i know more about the genre and
i've seen a lot more of them
i can appreciate it a lot more and say
that it's like it's actually a really
it's a really good example of the genre
and particularly one like i said if i
was making a list of
you know for somebody that was just
starting out in jello films it's like
here's 10 that you should start with or
here's 10 that you should see that are
really good i think this would
definitely be on there
um you know it's just a really good one
that has a lot of the classic tropes but
is kind of doing its own thing as well
but yeah so as i said shutter just added
this
not too long ago as of when this is
recorded so hopefully it's still there
if you want to check it out
but maybe you can find it elsewhere as
well as i said this is called what have
you done to
solange uh it also has a couple of and
it came out in 1972 if i didn't mention
that before
it also had a couple of other english
languages i've never heard it called
anything
other than what it's normally called but
i do like that one of its alternate
titles because it's an italian movie and
you know that it's going to have like 40
000
like alternate titles because that's
just what they did
but one of the alternate titles was the
school that couldn't scream
which i love that i don't know why i
like that so much it's just
it's a terrible title and it's just if
you think about it it doesn't make any
sense
but i don't know i i'm just kind of into
that and that just made me chuckle like
when i saw that that was one of the
alternate titles
but yeah i just i'm i'm really into i
really love glo movie titles and i
really love
italian movies and all the crazy
alternate titles that they
have been given over the years there's
just something very amusing
maybe that's just me i don't know but
it's amazing to me anyway so i just
thought i'd mention it
but yeah it's on shutter go check it out
if you like jl movies and haven't seen
it
then it's probably one that you should
check out
because you know it's a very good
example of the genre as i said
and that will do it for this flickers of
fear i will see you guys
on the next one bye